from the very beginning of this course
is designed for this semester we wanted
to to connect the humanities the
classroom with social justice and
luckily we had guest speakers who
themselves have been engaged in social
change so for example I mentioned before
gentlemen there's also put the Fox
Harrell in fact most of our death
speakers have been engaged in in real
life trying to make change for social
justice and because some of our students
were themselves children of immigrants
many of them got very interested for
example in the issue of migration or to
protect the rights of migrants who have
been under attack
in the in the recent couple of years
thanks to John Thurman some of the
students connected to the Mara group
which is dusit immigrant and refugee and
poughkeepsie coalition and and and they
were actually very happy to do so to be
able to connect not only the personal
biography is but also the the classroom
work with actual action for social
change and and we also got to understand
the ways in which what we're studying in
this course for example the issue of
language and elimination have impact say
in the courtroom so the issue of
language information was particularly
evident in the court case of George
Zimmerman the trial of the man who was
accused of killing Trayvon Martin this
young black boy who was in in his book
in his neighborhood after seeing his dad
and it was after he bought some skittles
and some drinks and he was killed by
this vigilante and and the reason why he
was acquitted is because the star
witness for the prosecution Rachel
jeantel who happen to be this young
woman of Haitian and and Dominican
descent and because of the way she spoke
she spoke with a black accent and that
accent and the malleability in fact some
of the jurors were clear that they would
not believe her because she founded
because of the way she spoke and there's
a beautiful analysis of this of this
episode very sad episode by John
Rickford and Charisse King in
Journal in the tonal language where they
should very clearly that that was the
main factor for Rachel jeantel to not be
believed by the jury so here this is a
clear case where I did suppose language
have a have an impact on on social
justice